bien loin des grands soirs bonsoir merci
d'être là bonsoir tout le monde nous
arrivait de vacances là vous êtes
bronzés non non non c'est sous le
maquillage enfin si j'étais en vacances
mais je suis pas brosser ouais c'est une
apparence ouais ça va
ouais
ouais j'ai des soucis jeu que des trucs
nouveaux donc c'est toujours des soucis
mais oui on va en parler vous faites de
la chanson maintenant je sais pas si
tout le monde ici connaît michel
houellebecq en tous les cas c'était un
écrivain formidable
d'abord il avait écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelait extension du domaine de la
lutte qui était adapté au cinéma
d'ailleurs par philippe harel
ensuite il a fait les particules
élémentaires qui est un moment
extrêmement important et que je vous
conseille de lire si vous n'avez déjà
fait ça s'est vendu coup à 300000
exemplaires oui par bon y'a encore donc
quelques millions de gens qui peuvent
l'acheter ça a été traduit en 25 langues
ce qu'il trouve que a priori à quelque
chose ça devait être adapté au cinéma
par pia l'asse pas fait ça non
ça va être adapté au cinéma mais je sais
pas par qui ouais alors les particules
élémentaires donc voilà on peut
l'acheter
vous publiez vous avez publié en
septembre naissance donc
vous dites on passait dans un recueil de
poésie oui mais vous dit en parlant de
renaissance je vais profiter de ma zone
manga ressent vite je vais profiter de
ma nouvelle notoriété pour est sorti
d'essayer de sortir la poésie de son
ghetto
bas tout le monde de oui oui des cons
beaucoup de gens ont essayé ouais
moi j'essaye je suis pas le premier à
vous ai trouvé un système en tous les
cas pour sortir la poésie de son ghetto
mouillé oui je sais que vous avez un cd
ben oui
c'est une bonne formule en faire de la
musique en même temps quand on trouve la
musique qui va ça peut pas arriver à
chaque fois là vous allez trouver
bientôt ça va bertrand burgalat qui
signe les musiques et ça va être votre
votre présence au printemps de bourges
va être le 20 avril sans doute
l'événement du printemps de bourges
alors voilà ouais ça en fait c'est une
vachement bonne idée de mettre des
poèmes en musique ce qui est plus
délicat c'est l'idée que j'interprète
moi même mais ça c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas trouvé donc si un interprète
quelconque à les coins comme quoi tout
est possible tout est possible nous a
fait pas tout est possible mais
j'aimerais dire aux autres muraille bien
coûter deux millions aussi la donne il y
en beaucoup
si vous voulez voir houellebecq sur
scène donc il ya le 20 avril le
printemps de bourges
il faut fait une tournée oui ça sera
peut-être mieux parce que là ce n'est
pas encore tout à fait au point enfin on
va essayer que ce soit bien
c'est plus sûr on met fin mels et 3 mai
à paris aux folies pigalle c'est à lyon
au transbordeur qu'à trouver toute une
poésie une tournée l'image d'angoulême
toulouse bordeaux rennes en fait tout
une tournée monaco
voilà bah oui là ça devrait
m policiers pour tes tableaux d'art est
ce que vous arrivez dans la littérature
on vous souhaite le même succès dans le
disque parce que votre bouquin elle
sorti comme ça d'un seul coup ça a été
je me souviens la rentrée 81,18 les
particules élémentaires c'était le livre
ça l'est toujours d'ailleurs on en parle
toujours au moins une fois par semaine
ah ouais bah oui une fois par semaine ne
vous suffit pas si si c'est énorme ouais
avec le recul de michel houellebecq
comment vous réagissez aujourd'hui
comment vous considérez les polémiques
qui ont suivi la la parution des
particules élémentaires chez flammarion
mais c'est bien qu'ils aient des
polémiques en france son pays
sympathique pour que ça enfin il ya des
polémiques sur les livres ouais il ya
une polémique dedans votive enfin je
veux pas raconter votre liste sessegnon
le jour ni l'heure mais disons qu'il y
avait plusieurs thèmes et notamment une
critique des moeurs libérales et des
dérive laxiste de mai 68 qui est un peu
le enfin le thème si bien qu'à pas de
critique du film la parenthèse enchantée
ou ouzou clotilde courau avec vincent
elbaz géraldine paillasse
karin viard
voilà l'exemple le même
michel l'exemple même alors d'un enfant
de 68 là depuis depuis le début de la
soirée n'arrive pas la tenir on sent
bien qu'elle a été qu elle a été élevée
par des parents baba cool c'est évident
mais puisqu il a bien parlé de ça dans
son bouquin les singes là les sages
depuis que vous êtes là les sages mais
moi je sais pas les maisons faut se
débrouiller comme ils pouvaient ben oui
exact vous avez vous avait choqué
d'abord en disant ça parce que c'est
vrai que c'était la première fois où un
auteur un écrivain 10 et bat critique et
68 en dix ans charles manson serait pas
été possible 168 donc d'un coup ça a mis
tout le monde devant ses responsabilités
là je caricature un peu mais c'est ça
l'esprit bapaume ça à peine malause way
à peine malheureusement tu es vous
disiez en dans votre bouquin puis dans
les interviews données par la suite que
finalement 68 c'était surtout pour vous
le triomphe de l'industrie du
divertissement
oui mais je maintiens mes c
façon quand on dit un truc pour la
première fois on peut toujours se
tourner les ennuis oui le mec qui a dit
que la terre classiquement l oeil des
emmerdes au ciel et puis alors il y
avait aussi ceux de votre bouquin qui a
choqué les gens c'est que c'est la
première fois qu'on décrivait des scènes
érotiques non satisfaisante parce
qu'habituellement dans l'est dans les
films érotiques dans les livres
érotiques tout le monde jouit tout le
monde est content et et vous vous avez
vous avez mangé de la sexualité avec
réalise non ouais mais elles sont pas
non satisfaisante non plus sur ses
moyens que c'est lui c'est la réalité
quoi c'est comme dans la vie lui
satisfaisants et du pas satisfaisant que
c'est vrai que c'est
bon c'est pas de l'érotisme de sexualité
réel voilà ça ça a beaucoup choqué aussi
parce que c'est ouais mais des histoires
de sexe est toujours vachement bien tout
le monde est content en fait le truc
hein je vais vous dire dites-moi michel
le grand secret dans l'histoire c'est
que là le point culminant des scènes
n'est pas la sexualité dans mes scènes
sûr que ça continue après donc la
sexualité un moment qu'intervient au
milieu
une fin en soi quoi au wef assez
parce que dans tous les films qu'ils
soient porno ou sentimentaux ça finit
toujours par le point le plus sexuel
alors que moi je continue après fui je
deviens moins drôle tout ça est
nécessaire que les gens continuent à
parler après et donc sexualité est
intégré dans nos une narration
une réflexion sur les films pornos vous
dites que dans les années 70 les
actrices de films porno était moins
jolie qu'aujourd'hui à quoi c'est dû à
votre avis on bosse assez simple c'est
parce que
maintenant que tout le monde accepte de
fines faire des films pornos donc il ya
plus de concurrence donc fait les plus
belles qui ont le leur que dans les airs
70 c'est celle qui voulait un peu qu'il
ait tourné à quoi donc effectivement les
films pornos sont devenus moins réaliste
du coup parce qu'on est les filles sont
plus jolis coups est ce qu a beaucoup
choqué les gens dont il ya eu
effectivement cette critique de 68 il ya
eu cette façon de raconter la sexualité
d'une façon très quotidienne comme ça
très réel est bien aussi toutes les
limitations du corps humain parce que
vous dites vous fassiez pas dans le
bouquin mais vous dites dans les
interviews moi l'idée d'un seul sexe ne
semble pas mal ça serait bien qu'on ait
des clitoris des glands un peu partout
sur le corps mais des heures de plaisir
il ya plein d'idées mais c'est planant
épisode est comme ça aussi c'est bizarre
c'est l'introduction
dans les michel c'est vrai c'est
l'introduction de la science fiction
dans le roman
mais ça
non mais j'ai beaucoup chez politique
tout ça
moi j'ai beaucoup choqué
j'ai beaucoup choqué parce que moi je
n'étais pas contre les mutations
génétiques ouais et donc le
tout les trucs
génétique bizarre qu'on fait moi je
trouve que vous n'êtes pas content le
clonage vous non non je suis pas contre
que c'est une tendance inéluctable
clonage et qui finira toute façon le
clonage humain finira par sa probable
est donc ça finira par s'imposer comme
mode de reproduction je pense oui ayez
confiance
alors on vous a accusé ce qui est
incroyable c'est que vous accusez de
véhicules et des fantasmes eugénique
très habile et totalitaire alors que
vous vous placez la compassion au dessus
de toutes les qualités humaines
quelqu'un vraiment compassionnel bah oui
ou el bec à 20 ans il a mis un coup de
pied à un pigeon et il dit c'est ce que
j'ai fait plus méchant dans ma vie et je
m'en veux encore est sympa ben oui j'ai
pas fait
je peux fait pire
ils en souffrent toujours mais oui ce
pauvre pigeon je sais pas c'était nous
avons changé l'america et un bled
pas délinquants
j'ai pas pourquoi les bons c'est vrai
que les pigeons temps en temps il a
beaucoup c'est agaçant appareil je sais
pas qui est qui et de l'allemagne paris
c'est monsieur blanc j'en suis moi il ya
eu votre livre a fait a fait scandale et
pour la bonne cause je dirais en
revanche il ya eu un scandale si vous
n'aviez pas le prix goncourt qua non
c'était de plus de plus sérieux et de
plus grave en parlant du prix goncourt
que vous n'avez pas eu vous avez dit mon
éditeur en l'occurrence flammarion
n'avait pas de ligne budgétaire pour
acheter les jurés bah oui mais ça c'est
pas un scoop enfin bon il paraît que
c'est un scoop qu'on écrive un 10 mais
c'est la première fois qu'un écrivain
dit il est entendu des éditeurs le dire
donc je n'avais pas l'impression de dire
un truc si choquant que ça ouais je
croyais que c'est tout le monde tout le
monde le savait déjà quoi
oui ça se passe pas comme ça c'est à
dire qui leur demandent une préface et
au vu de leur pays la préface 5000
francs et leur paye la préface 50 mille
francs tragédie ça un peu imprudemment
mais je pensais que tout le monde le
savait maintenant voyez enfin tout le
monde le savait personne ne disait
alors il ya une chose pour terminer avec
vous michel houellebecq qui vous
resterait au delà de tout ça comme le
premier qui a dénoncé les inégalités
sexuelles qu'on avait déjà dénoncé
toutes les formes d'inégalités et vous
vous avez été le premier l'a aussi à
dire un peu comme sur le concours était
le premier à dire que la compétition
sexuelle et plus sauvage que la computer
co la compétition capitaliste et qu'en
fait il ya aucune loi dans ce domaine
tous les coups sont permis c'est la loi
du plus fort ça aussi c'est quelque
chose était le premier à énoncer c'est à
dire qu'en fait là la vraie compétition
c'est la compétition sexuelle et celle
là il n'y a pas d'égalité possible en
plus bas nous je suis désolé d'avoir
énoncé cette chose des prix montent mais
je n'ai rien à retrancher là oui je sais
c'est qu'ils ont plus tard évidemment il
ya les clubs échangistes ça c'est le
communisme sexuelle c'est l'offre oui
faut déjà de prolongation voilà c'est le
club échangiste m'en fasse tuer alors la
compétition en revanche c'est d'ailleurs
la discothèque c'est la compétition et
c'est dur mais faut pas c'est vrai que
l'on
est on est samedi vers 1h du matin
il ya probablement des gens qui rentrent
déprimé il sera sur canal en train de
regarder
on va alors vous savez qu'on ne bouge
pas paru jean galle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux faire une interview fin du monde
que vous êtes quelqu'un de spécial
mangue et comme on vient de le voir
l'interview fin du monde
alors c'est la fin du monde michel oui
les cordeaux c'est la fin du monde si
vous deviez sauver un livre moi je
prendrais la bible ouais parce que bon
c'est pas abouti
mais on peut refaire plein à partir de
la bible donc c'est très générateur quoi
il ya plein de petites histoires on peut
saluer a beaucoup servi pour refaire des
livres à partir de si vous deviez sauver
un animal ou bichon frisé le bichon
frisé oui vous aimez les bichons frisés
oui c'est magnifique votre grand mère
avait un bichon frisé
baisse et comme c'est un tout petit
chien c'est comme une peluche c'est
toujours le team n non ça boit pas
beaucoup et bien pas du tout n'ont
presque pas et ça vous sautent dessus ça
vous laisse en fait c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
aussi je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être les l'idée de la preuve
mathématique ouais ça c'est bien ça
beaucoup s'inscrivent nous simplifie la
question suivante un disque est un trop
le vôtre non non en béton avant le sait
mieux c'est un film peut-être murnau
l'aurore ouais si vous aviez sauver un
sexe social non
mais ça veut dire se pose même pas une
drogue ben moi je dirais le tabac ça
l'air de rien mais c'est bien si vous
deviez sauver un homme politique ce
serait qui
tuvéri tiberi 60
je sais pas j'ai rien contre
j'ai plaisir à monsieur moi ou bon
honnêtement j'aime bien chevènement mai
désolé désolé pour les plus futiles eu
un coup de pied comme le pigeon
non j'aime bien chevènement chevènement
ah ouais ouais je trouve qu'il est
courageux bas les jeunes bon dieu qui
l'a sauvé une fois il ya d'écouté bien
possible écoutez bien on rallume
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux